Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here again,
and I'm back in Vancouver back in
front of my real bookshelf, not the
curtain that I use in Palm Springs.
And today I wanna talk about a question or
answer question that I get very often, and
that is, which language should I study?
You know, people say, you know,
I'm very interested in French, but
I also am interested in Chinese.
And so which one should I study and
can I study two at the same time?
All kinds of questions around the
subject of what language to study.
So my answer is, you know, in
some cases we have no choice.
So if you're going to work for
a German company in Germany,
obviously you're gonna learn German.
If, uh, future employers are
at demanding a certain level of
English, then you have no choice.
So there are situations where we have no
choice, but typically people who ask the
question "which language should I study?"
are not in that situation.
They are people who are learning
languages out of interest.
And since motivation is such a
big factor in language learning
success, the obvious answer is which
language are you keenest to learn?
Where where are you most enthusiastic?
And the motivation to learn a
language can be, you know, anything.
I've often said that it's, it's a pity
that in Canada, in the school system, kids
in the English language school system are
forced to learn French because that is one
of the two official languages of Canada.
That's not a very strong motivator.
To some extent, I believe it doesn't
matter what you study, because
once you get going, once you start
learning language and you know how
to learn languages and you've done
it once and you've been successful.
You can learn as many languages as
you want and uh, as you have time for.
And so if kids in our, just to digress,
in our English language school system
in Canada, were allowed to choose
the language they wanted to learn,
they're more likely to succeed and
therefore enjoy language learning and
therefore go on to learn other language.
By forcing them to learn French,
because it's the official language,
you end up discouraging a lot of people
who are forced to learn a language.
They're not very motivated to learn.
Now, insofar as you know,
motivation to learn a language,
it can be many different things.
If you see, if you look at the bookshelf
behind me and in particular the two
skinny bookshelves that are full of CDs.
We don't need CDs any longer because
we can download audio from the internet
but I have material there in Czech, in
uh, Japanese, in French, in German, in
Swedish, um, Russian, uh, you name it.
And similarly books, Latin even.
I have books in latin.
So any number of things
can trigger your interest.
Right now, for example,
I'm focusing on Polish.
I did some Danish because I'm gonna
be in Denmark and then in Poland.
So a trip to the country
can be a motivator.
So obviously if you're about to go
to a country, you're very, or if
you know you're gonna go there in
six months, that's a big motivator.
It could be a person, you know,
I found, uh, some of the CDs in
themselves motivating because they
were so interesting to listen to.
So, uh, but I, I still say
in a way it doesn't matter.
Any time you invest in learning
a language, it's with you
and you can always go back.
I have taken various stabs at learning
Korean prior to going to Korea, or
for whatever reason, or maybe I think
initially I was motivated to learn Korean
because it seemed to me that it would
be easy after Chinese and Japanese.
That turned out not to be
a very strong motivator.
The idea that a language might be
easy may not be as strong a motivator
as I'm gonna go to the country, or
I have a friend, or I'm interested
in anime in the case of Japanese.
So you have to make sure that
the motivation is deep enough.
So in my case with Korea and the fact
that it's similar to, not similar,
but the Japanese and Chinese help
me in learning Korean was in itself
not a strong enough motivation.
Uh, when I was in Korea recently, four
years ago and, uh, was speaking some
Korean, then that kind of motivated me.
But then when I went away and I didn't
go back to Korean or to Korea, then
my motivation declined somewhat.
So it's important to find sort of
a motivator that is gonna keep you
motivated, and very often that's just
the enjoyment of the language itself,
the enjoyment of discovering things in
the language, reading about the history
of the country and so forth and so on.
But I, I guess my conclusion
on all of this is that which
language should you learn?
It doesn't really matter.
Uh, even if you're only motivated for
a short period of time and then you
lead that language and study some other
language, none of that is lost because
when you go back to that language, you
will very soon pick up where you left off.
So I like having quite a few
sort of irons in the fire.
Uh, I've left my Arabic, I mean,
my Arabic is pretty bad right now.
I was a lot better even a year ago, but
then I've spent more time on Persian and
I'm spending time on, you know, I was
spending time on Danish and now on Polish.
All good.
You know, you don't lose anything.
And as for this question of,
should I study two languages
at the same time, or not?
Again, it depends on your
motive, uh, motivation.
Um, obviously if you stay with
one language, you're gonna
learn that language faster.
If you try to do two languages at the
same time, you will discover a little
bit about two languages, but you won't
progress as far in the one language.
Although sometimes, if you feel that
you're not making progress in one language
and then you go to a second language
and it's fresh and new for you, and so
you have a sense of achievement in that
language, then when you go back to the
first one, uh, you're kind of refreshed.
The batteries are charged up
and you quickly pick up where
you left off and drive forward.
So I guess my conclusion is, you know,
if you are in a situation where you
have to learn a language, try to find
something motivating about the language
because you're gonna have to learn it.
On the other hand, if you are in a
position where you have the luxury
of choosing which language to learn,
go with your mood at the moment.
If you're more motivated,
motivated to learn language a at a
certain point in time, go for it.
When the motivation for that language
seems to sag, go and do another language.
A language you're very motivated to learn.
You can always come back to the first one.
Nothing lost.
Uh, tasting different languages
in different ways is always
satisfying, always pleasurable.
And uh, and the main thing is not to
worry about how well you're doing, uh,
if you don't have to learn the language.
You don't have to write an
exam if you're doing it out of.
Don't compare yourself.
Don't be too demanding of yourself.
Just enjoy whatever you're
doing in the language.
As Lomb Kato once said, uh, foreign
language is one thing that is
worth learning, even imperfectly
or words to that effect...
or learning poorly.
So there is never a negative
to learning a language.
So I would go with a mood of the moment.
Which language am I most
motivated to learn right now?
And that's my answer on which
language should I learn.
I hope that was helpful.